the democrats are not letting a crisis
go to waste biden's energy secretary now
using russia's invasion of ukraine to
push their green agenda
we heard president zielinski we do not
want to see
any country that is held hostage to
vladimir putin
and this is a moment for congress to be
able to act
there can be a compromise there can be
movement on this this is a moment to
have this happen it's an urgent moment
and while americans feel the pain in
their pockets every time they go to fill
up their tanks the media is thrilled the
president gave them someone else to
blame
can we have an honest conversation about
gas prices because too much of the u.s
media chatter is distorted to the point
of being dishonest
higher gas prices is a small sacrifice
to make compared to what the the brave
ukrainians are going through many
politicians act as though it's president
biden who caused inflation and that he
can fix this no i mean you know he did
not cause the war which caused prices to
surge and you heard the president united
states say putin's price hike and
putin's price hike is a great way to
message it
you know what if ever there were a
question as to whether or not the
mainstream media is the trumpet for the
for the left and for the biden
administration i mean you just saw it i
mean everything that biden says they say
you know the reason gas prices are going
up is because of of uh ukraine it's all
about the war but americans aren't that
stupid greg are they i mean they put gas
in their tanks they know what they paid
before the war they did they are trying
they're trying to ban domestic drilling
as they say it's a putin price hike
that's like that's like kicking somebody
in the head and then blaming it on the
donkey down the road no the price hike
is a consequence of bite inflation and
how do you know that because oil isn't
the only thing going up baby food bacon
furniture bedding watches jewelry that's
all going up if it was just gas then you
could say maybe this that the other no
it's all of these things but the
weirdest contradiction is that the dems
are blaming putin for the gas
inflation but they already wanted it to
go up shouldn't they be thanking him for
the for for helping to reduce our carbon
emissions because after all it was
russia who infiltrated the green groups
to get us off our domestic oil and buy
their foreign oil it was the radical
green agenda that ended up working for
putin they were putin's puppet the whole
time all those celebrities that were
telling us how bad fracking was and how
bad the pipelines were they were being
funded by russia it's amazing well you
know jesse if they were being funded by
russia has anybody given thought to the
fact that this war if you want to talk
about carbon emissions i mean talk about
the bombs the buildings i mean how about
the nuclear site i mean there's like
something john kerry would say yeah
carbon emissions real problems going on
for the war right maybe we should have
gotten in earlier and ended it that's a
good point you know what stop global
warming stop the war thank you secretary
kerry i filled up my tank this morning
in new jersey well i didn't do it the
guy did it because you're not allowed to
do it there and i have a big tank judge
so it took a while what do you have an
escalade yes a guy comes out
and you have an escalator
don't laugh geraldo i have one because
then we know what you're man of the
people has an escalator this is a guy
who has a bentley bentley
you've never even pumped your own gas or
all though so the guy the guy comes out
i says aziz because his is he is on this
thing i said i point to the price i said
how did you guys set that today it's at
4 30 this morning
and he says well i get a phone call
every morning and they say what the
price is supposed to be
and i'm like does rex tillerson call you
i'm thinking this big you know oil baron
as geraldo would say he says no my uncle
calls me and he tells me and i go oh
your uncle owns the shop i said well how
does your uncle know the price every day
and he goes well the oil price is about
50 the other 50 my uncle tells me i said
get your uncle on the phone
he picks up this phone he calls and the
uncle gets on the phone i said how'd you
set the price and he said who is this
jesse never and and he goes he goes we
almost went out of business the last two
years right he said the price of oil was
really low no one was driving because of
covet he goes we almost went bankrupt he
goes i almost had to sell the business
and i said well okay now that things are
back how do you set the price he goes oh
i don't even know what the price is
going to be i don't know if russia is
winning i don't know if russia's losing
i don't know if covin's coming back so
we keep it here and i go all right well
and he goes i don't even want it too
high he goes if it gets too high then no
one comes in and fills up their tank he
goes i want it lower but he goes i have
to make a living and i go now i have to
go make a living i got to go back to new
york but it's not a conspiracy gerald
though the price is set by the neighbor
though he looks over there and the guy's
got 4 30. so what's he going to do 429
429 he's he's going to put 428 i mean
that's the american way i i think
competition will set the price but i i i
just said yesterday
let me tell you
let me tell you one thing about uh let
bucko say one thing about a jennifer
brown home and the whole green energy
business i wish they would just shut up
they are right about the future and
green energy and electric vehicles and
all that they're right about that just
shut up let the world evolve into the
brief the brave new situation but the
more you stick it especially now when
people are really hurting at the pump
and elsewhere and there's a war raging
the more you stick it to them green
energy green energy the less
relevant you seem to me it's the way to
marginalize your movement is to talk
about it at exactly the wrong moment and
not only that degen you've got to
transition what should we do just shut
down everything that's a combustible
engine or fracking or oil or gas and
just go right to green energy how do we
do that they don't have a plan no they
don't have a plan and to put an
exclamation point on the moronicy of
their green agenda it's called global
warming as in the globe and the world so
they want us to not drill not explore
not produce oil and natural gas but
they're overseas begging saudi arabia
and venezuela and even iran to keep
pumping oh baby pump some more but it
does that has no
no net effect on global warming because
a derrick
over there is the same as a derrick here
except our production is actually much
more energy efficient and cleaner better
cleaner for the environment so that's
the idiocy of that policy but geraldo
when i and i
said something about you on the air this
morning and i'll say it to your face
when you did you hurt my feelings well
when you talked about gouging the fat
gat oil barons right i said wake rip van
winkle up it's not 1910 it's the 21st
century i stand by my position listen to
me record profits over the last seven
years jesse's point
five percent i'm not talking about
no i'm saying that the service stations
the big oils they don't own the service
stations
that five percent less than five percent
are owned by big oil companies the vast
majority are owned by mama and dad and
aziz's uncle right and so if you have a
problem if you actually filled up your
bentley and didn't use mustache wax and
like glitter and bacon grease to fuel it
potentially then you would know if you
got out of your car and went in and did
what jesse did have been a man of the
people and talked to the folks you would
know that they're hesitant to lower the
price up faster than they are because
what happened today oil prices spiked
and so they're they don't want to get
stuck yeah let's wait and see yeah we
got to go hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else